your pal Dax Shepard was on the show not
too long ago yes he's very handsome
yeah he's it sure all right fine I'm
only saying that because everybody says
we look alike well I was gonna say that
Dax Shepard was talking about how you
two looked so much alike and then I
guess someone on the internet did a face
whoa is actually Chris no you guys Oh
Kristen Kristen Bell thought it would be
funny list to a face swap and they did a
face walk with you two guys and no one
could tell is that right yeah we brought
it for I think yeah we have this and we
we showed it with Dax - you have the
exact it's really wrong all for our very
good look those are four of the
best-looking people I've ever seen yeah
yeah this kind of went super viral all
over the earth yeah yeah I guess a lot
of people think we look alike yeah
people think I look like a lot of people
like that's the other thing there's a
life I've gotten this there's a whole
website what do they say you look like
Ray Romano a young John Ritter double
the last bachelor from the from the
bachelor show and that's the ways
ex-boyfriend that went to jail that's so
funny people come up to you in the
street and go hey it's in the Hathaways
ex-boyfriend he went to jail by the way
I did Eddie Murphy once came up to me
and I was like I need Murphy's like a
Godhead Tim yeah and he goes anyone ever
tell you look like an otherwise
boyfriend the way to jail like No yeah I
mean yeah and he goes yeah was watching
the news and I was like that looks like
the dude from scrubs my only experience
with one of my heroes is him telling me
that I look like a criminal yeah that's
so weird so and so you get I'm the only
person I get mistaken for sometimes is
actresses great sort of beautiful
actresses in their in their mere
politician to you once I looked a lot
like the president of Finland who was I
remember who was a 65 year old woman
that's what all I get who's the woman
that you'd get mistaken who I was
getting mistaken for and what's your
name who is it
Tilda Swinton yeah Tilda Swinton
whatever you're way prettier than her
thank you
men are always asking me out it's fun
but you know there's a website yeah
called it's called Zach Braff as
everyone oh I haven't seen that one
there was another one called
men who looked like Zach Braff but let's
see what this one is this one is they
just put your it's just a whole website
that fans put together and they put your
face on other people like Jack McBrayer
from 30 rock President Obama I'm not
sure yeah there's one view as Jesus I
think that's kind of a jaunty Jesus well
I'll see you around
extra Jewish Jesus they also did what
someone put your face on just a random
family an entire have you seen that well
I got sent that someone put my face on a
whole family and I don't have a wife and
kids yet so I often sort of co-opted
this and I send it out as my holiday
card and I say I say from me and my
family this is very popular it
looking family it's available I send
that out almost every holiday saying hey
Happy Happy Thanksgiving from the
Braff's yeah
that's really sad yeah it's being worked
on
you